We're officially entering the completely
insane phase of the 2016 election.
I know it feels like we've been here for
about a year now,
but if you think the political theater
has been crazy so far,
trust me.
You ain't seen nothing yet.
It seems that everyone you know is
starting to crack,
right?
I mean,
you could just open up twitter or
facebook and every second of the day it
seems like someone is writing something
crazy.
Nobody has a clue as to what's going on
anymore and you don't have to take my
word for that.
Just turn on CNN or Fox or MSNBC and
listen to the pundits who got everything
wrong for the last six months.
Explain how the next six months are
going to go.
These are the experts in what I have no
idea.
Last week I discussed what I consider to
be the biggest risk of a trump
presidency.
We have a salesman doing a hell of a
sales job,
but we really don't know what kind of
product we're going to end up with.
In the end.
As some of you pointed out,
the notion of not knowing how someone
will act once in office is actually no
different than with most politicians.
They pretty much all will say anything
to get elected and then do whatever they
can to stay in power.
Ironically,
this endless loop of promises made and
broken by politicians who just want to
stay in office is exactly what has led
to the rise of Donald trump.
People are sick of the status quo and
are willing to turn into a reality TV
host as their savior.
Some of you pointed out if my question
of whether trump would even believe in
our three branches of government was
legit.
Many presidents have done plenty via
executive action,
effectively circumventing congress and
usually like in the case of Barack
Obama,
they against using executive actions
until they're in office themselves.
Of course,
presidents shouldn't get all the blame
for executive actions.
It's not as if this congress has been
eager to get anything done with the
president.
Regardless of WHO's to blame.
Though the average person sees usurping
of power and Washington gridlock in
their minds,
is a regular politician going to get our
country out of that pattern?
No,
but an over the top businessman might.
While we can parse out why trump has
risen,
the fact is he is here and all of us
have to acknowledge there is a political
movement brewing on the horizon.
It may not be the one you would like,
but trying to silence trump supporters
by blocking roads to rallies or by
labeling all his supporters.
Racist isn't going to stop his rise.
Actually,
it's just going to make his support that
much stronger.
This is why I always talk about the
battle of ideas on this show and it's
not only why I talk about them,
it's why I invite guests from all over
the political map to share in their
views and guess what?
Yeah.
Sometimes they say things that I don't
agree with,
but I don't shout them down.
The only way we can ever make progress
is by hearing others.
This should be the number one principle
of being a progressive,
but these days it's not even on their
top 10 list.
If you hate trump,
if you think his comments about Muslims
are horrible,
if you think his border wall is terrible
and you think his general disposition is
disgusting,
then use your speech to promote a
candidate with better ideas.
If you like Bernie,
that helped Bernie get the vote out.
If you like Hillary,
then tell your friends why.
If you like Ted Cruz,
well then you're the only one,
but good for you.
The point is,
we've never needed a battle of ideas
more in this country than we do right
now and we shouldn't be afraid to have
it,
but here's the scary part.
A battle of ideas means actually hearing
people out,
so yes,
you can use your free speech to protest
trump or anyone else that's as American
as it gets,
but big goddamn deal.
If you're offended,
suck it up and move on like you should
have learned in fourth grade.
Do you think the people who blocked the
road to the trump rally changed the mind
of one person that they stopped from
getting there?
No.
They actually did the complete opposite
because they didn't have a battle of
ideas.
They had a battle of Mad Max fury road
on a highway in Arizona.
My guest this week is the infamous
notorious and always outspoken Milo
Yiannopoulos.
Milo is a provocateur who's rise to
start them in some ways.
Mirrors trumps which might explain his
support for the Donald Milo is using all
the tools of the Internet to spread his
message against the authoritarians.
Not only does he always get a reaction,
but he's paid the price,
losing his blue twitter verification
check and being protested at several
universities on his current college
tour.
He sort of a micro trump and that he
uses the media to a fuel his ascent to
start them.
While I have many differences of opinion
with Milo,
we find ourselves as allies in the war
on free speech and against ideologies
that would silence us both.
There is way more that unites us as a
people and as a country.
Then the media will ever tell us
decency,
respect,
and humanity just aren't very clickable.
For riots,
protests and violence will always be the
lead story,
thus fueling the fire of intolerance.
That's why I said you ain't seen nothing
yet.
We could end up with a contested
convention for the Republicans,
a super delegate revolt by the
Democrats,
a sudden third party candidate,
or who knows what else.
The important thing is that we learn to
respect one another while this insane
process unfolds around us.
If our leaders aren't going to be great,
then it's time for us to do some leading
ourselves.
Milo Yiannopoulos is a senior staff
editor for Breitbart News,
a speaker,
and has been named the ultimate trolls
by the fusion network,
Milo Yiannopoulos.
Welcome back to the show.
Thank you so much for having me.
Well,
it was supposed to come back.
You are the second.
Well,
maybe the third or the fourth.
I know you want to be first at
everything.
I'm.
I'm joint generally am.
In fact,
it's better than that.
I'm normally way ahead of my time.
In fact,
I'm normally so earlier everything that
people think I'm crazy until six months
later than I used to have a guy that I
wrote comedy with who used to always
say,
Dave,
we're so ahead of the curve or behind
it.
So maybe that's,
maybe that's me.
Maybe this one.
So unpopular.
I don't know.
We've had a couple,
a couple of repeat guests,
but in a way you're sort of the most
important.
Not that I have to inflate your ego
because I know you like that,
but a tremendous amount of stuff has
happened since we had you on.
So you were on,
I think it was the middle of October.
So we're only,
we're five or six months away from that.
Right?
It's going great by the way.
Thank you.
Love it.
Um,
and a lot has happened in this space
that we exist,
this cultural libertarian space.
So we got,
we got a lot to get to,
but let's start with what's happening
today.
So,
uh,
this morning,
there was this terror attack in Brussels
at the airport and at a train station
over there,
uh,
it's still unfolding.
So right now we're taping this,
it's Tuesday afternoon here in Los
Angeles.
So some stuff obviously will change.
Uh,
why don't you just give me your initial
thoughts on what's going on.
Well,
this is sort of what liberalism is
welcomed into Europe.
Um,
you know,
uh,
this is the excuse making that's been
made for radical Islam,
which has prevented us from fighting
this problem by people who lie about the
source of these people in new stations
who refuse to accept that,
you know,
these,
these attacks have anything to do with
Islam and the people wouldn't even use
the word Muslim before it happens.
This is preventing us from fixing the
problem.
You know,
this is preventing people from taking
out of adequate security precautions,
you know,
looking after themselves.
Europe now,
you know,
welcoming in millions of people from
alien cultures,
whilst the establishment refuses to
accept that these people,
these people's belief systems are just
dramatically incompatible with our own.
And you know,
the regular citizenry as being aligned
to and light about constantly all the
time.
But the media on this stuff,
um,
we have population that is not able to
protect itself,
there is not adequately informed about
the risks,
the dangers of radical Islam.
And I'm the problem in Europe is that
this stuff is now happening everywhere.
No one is safe anywhere in Europe.
It's happening in Paris,
has happened in London.
It's happening in process.
No one is safe from this stuff.
And what does it go?
What our politicians leap to the airways
to say,
I really want to make it clear that has
nothing to do with Islam.
What it does it does.
And as a gay man,
you know,
I'm terrified by the prospect of mass
Muslim immigration into Europe is one of
the reasons I spend so much time in
America now.
I don't want to be there anymore.
Yeah.
So let's back up a little bit.
It's interesting that your initial
response to that is to talk about our
reaction to it rather than the ideology,
you know,
just nothing.
Surprises are not denying the ideology
or obviously,
yeah,
nothing surprises me about this.
Why are we surprised that Muslims are
blowing things up?
That's what they do,
like I don't care about that,
you know,
like it's,
it's a,
it's a horrific for the people who are,
who are on the receiving end of this
terrorist stuff.
It is.
Anybody surprised that isis blew
something up,
right?
So I'm gonna.
I'm gonna save you a little of Internet
hate.
You do make the distinction between the
nominal Muslim person,
the average person that's a Muslim,
that doesn't take their religion.
You don't need to.
You don't need to do me that favor.
No,
I don't care too much for that
distinction.
It is not extremists.
It's not radical Islamists.
It's people.
The security services,
uh,
worried about that.
Um,
you know,
that are the problem.
It is the silent majority Muslim.
So do nothing on,
in this situation,
have no peace movement,
no resistance to their own extreme
elements.
Just like the progressive left in the
West and 1111 countries.
You and I could be killed for who we
are.
That's not isis,
that is mainstream Muslim culture.
And we are importing that stuff into
Europe by millions.
No,
I don't make a meaningful distinction
between these things because I don't
care.
I don't see any reason to import these
cultures into liberal Western
democracies.
I see no reason to do it whatsoever.
And as Brigitte Gabriel wants,
very brilliantly said,
in any case,
the peaceful majority are irrelevant.
It is not the peaceful majority that
blow up buildings.
It is the extremists.
And right now in the world,
all of this stuff is coming from one
culture and one religion and I don't
want it here.
So what do we do about that?
Then what do you actually do?
We can't bomb these people into oblivion
with radical part of this as an
ideology,
right?
So how do you be an evil ideology?
We don't have to welcome one point 4
million of them into Germany.
We don't have to lie to people about
what Islam is and what Muslims believe,
which the press and politicians do all
the time.
We don't have to intervene in the
countries where it's not necessarily
where we don't need to and I was
supported the Iraq war,
but some of the other things we do in
the Middle East are not necessarily and
just drum up this,
this western hatred,
uh,
the,
some of what's gone on has something to
do with the West,
right?
No,
I'm not saying we're responsible for it.
You know,
nobody has that parsing out.
Blamed.
But you say you do see some connection,
right.
Where you would be an idiot to deny it.
You know,
we have been dealing with of idiots here
on the left.
There are a lot of it is Georgia.
Excellent.
Most of them say the reason I do your
show you on the very few liberal brain.
Yeah.
And there are starting to not think
that's a compliment.
A lot of people say that to me and I'm
starting to think maybe that's what I
mean.
Is it a compliment?
I don't know.
I mean,
it puts you up to average.
Is that a compliment?
No idea.
I mean,
look,
the problem is not just radical Islam.
The problem is Islam,
there are structural problems,
so this religion that mean it is
incompatible with modern free western
liberal democracy we live in and
particularly for you and I as a for you
and me and there's also a problem for
women.
There are very serious problems with
Islamic culture,
not Islamist jihadist,
a extremism and of course that plays
itself out and played itself out in the
streets of Brussels and it plays itself
out with far too much regularity,
but with Islam there is a problem and
nobody wants to talk about it and what
you tried to do earlier to save me from
myself,
I don't want it because now I respect
that I don't want it because I've got to
the point where I'm thinking,
look,
the West,
the West that Islam hates so much is
what has given us gay rights.
It has provided that for women it's
given women the vote.
It has ended slavery,
which is,
you know,
not the case everywhere.
Everywhere in the world it has given gay
people and women.
All of the rights we now enjoy.
There is effective blanket equality in
in the West for all of these people
and every other minority to exactly
importing Muslims is going to turn the
clock back and this is what you talk
about when you,
when you coin a coin and popularized
this phrase,
regressive left,
which came from this show,
right?
But you don't go far enough.
What?
What does the regressive left means?
It means it's going to take us backwards
into an era of hatred and bigotry.
Well,
the left seems to want to import Muslims
by the millions into all of our
countries.
That's the regressive consequence.
And it's not just terrorism.
So what do you think is going on with
these people?
I know many of these people very well.
I've worked with a lot of these people.
Well I don't anymore,
but this idea judge a man by his
friends,
you know,
but this ideology,
I mean even this morning on twitter as I
was scrolling through all the craziness
that every time there's a terror attack
or you know,
you get every,
you know,
avenue of craziness.
I saw someone,
a girl,
a 20 something year old girl in Belgium.
She actually tweeted that the Hashtag
Stop Islam,
the Hashtag itself.
She said,
that's worse than what actually
happened.
Mean that I'm not kidding.
I mean,
you see this every time you see this,
every time.
This is the left believes that words
have power.
They don't have.
They think that you can stop somebody
from being homophobic by banning the
word gay from the playground.
Um,
they think that you can end racism by
banning the n word.
They think that if you shape language
and a control culture that you can just
stamp out bigotry.
Well,
that's not how it works.
The point of a civilized society,
the point of,
uh,
of,
of etiquette and the point of
negotiating the world around us and
negotiating with other people is to live
with one another.
Despite our prejudices.
And despite our differences,
the purpose of a civilized society ought
to be to enable everybody to live
together in harmony,
which is why I hate what the gay lobby
does when it bullies and ridicules
Christians,
Christians not going away.
You know,
you're not gonna Bully Christianity out
of existence.
You're not gonna Ridicule Christianity
of existence just because buzzfeed
doesn't like people who believe in God.
Now he's had everybody to,
you know,
and we were doing a good job of that.
You know,
the West is doing a pretty good job of
that right up until we started importing
Muslims that,
I mean there's,
you're giving me a lot there.
That sort of is going to be the through
line for everything else we're going to
discuss.
Uh,
so,
you know,
let,
let's just jump into it.
Let's just go into some of the free
speech stuff.
So a lot of things have happened to you
over the past few months.
Your,
your star has risen the last you were
here,
you had a blue twitter verification
check.
You do not have it anymore.
You are,
as far as I know,
the only public person to have their
blue verification check for those that
don't know what it means.
I mean,
it basically means you are who you are,
so that if you're a celebrity or you're
just saying you are who you are,
that's it.
Yeah.
Right,
um,
but you had yours remove.
I don't think there's been any other
case of that happening and it clearly
was a punitive measure.
So just real quick though.
Sure.
I just want people to saying we're not
doing this to be so inside my little
twitter account,
got whatever,
but there's a bigger issue because
twitter is using,
I'm using a mechanism to protect public
figures like us from impersonation and
also their privilege concerns when
somebody's speaking to me in my role as
a journalist,
they have an expectation of privacy and
of legal privilege.
Now people are deeming people with my
name on twitter,
they're giving personal information
about their lives that exposes twitter
to liability too,
by the way.
There was very serious,
you know,
there's a reason why,
but it's a good idea to have public
figures,
um,
verify,
but they used it as an ideological
weapon.
And now when I went to the White House
to ask about this,
um,
asked Josh earnest about this and he
said very interestingly,
I thought the president would be the
first to affirm that the success of
these social networking companies rests
on their commitment to first amendment
principles.
Now,
he wasn't saying you can enforce the
first amendment are private companies.
And most I'd get thrown out of the
conservative club if I've tried to
suggest that.
And just to be clear,
the first amendment is about the
government taking away your free speech.
Now people are taking away,
uh,
the late Aaron Swartz,
the founder of Reddit said censorship
has a meaning outside the government
when private companies have a monopoly
on certain kinds of speech now to just
sit and he does not only because it has
such a stranglehold on journalism and
the media,
but also business invented entirely new
public square.
If you were in a pub and you make a joke
that involves race or sex or sex or
whatever,
and the Publican doesn't like it,
you can go to another pub down the road.
There is no other twitter,
right?
This is a fundamentally important part
of our media and our democracy.
So they're controlling basically one of
the big highways of information,
right?
And it comes out.
It comes with responsibility.
It comes responsibility to use this.
Do you want to two things.
One,
be honest and say,
you know what,
we're a liberal space,
period.
Conservative,
sooner or later you're going to get
banned.
We don't really want you here,
but you can stay for as long as you
know,
you don't piss us off too much.
Um,
and I pissed them off too much and they
have banned people not all the time,
always in one direction.
You always conservatively band.
Also,
I guess suspended now and again because
I make jokes about feminists,
feminists or whatever.
So like I said that I,
I said that I'd been appointed social
justice editor of Buzzfeed as a church.
A lot of people took you seriously.
It was quiet.
It was funny.
Idiots,
idiots.
Uh,
and then I,
and then immediately after that,
when people were tweeting Ben Smith,
I'm the boss and say,
how dare you?
Hi this man,
I'm never reading breastfeed again.
When I knew that it had taken hold,
then I,
then I started the hashtag feminism is
cancer.
Um,
and I did it polls,
you know,
would you rather your children had
feminism or cancer until 22,000
people voted and they voted for cancer.
And I had cancer survivors email,
uh,
acting may say I'm a two time cancer
survivor and I still chose counseling.
Funny.
That was funny.
Anyway,
that's.
They didn't like,
they didn't like that very much.
So yeah,
the point is,
if you are these days,
irreverent,
mischievous,
provocative,
and to do those things,
you have to be conservative because the
establishment is,
is,
is not just liberal but progressive
liberal.
Um,
if you want to be punk these days,
you want to be cool and dissident and
mischievous.
You have to be conservative.
And if you are that on twitter,
sooner or later you can lose your
account.
Now,
uh,
they should be honest about that.
Or they should,
they should enforce free speech and not
this weird.
There's weird definition of free speech
that Jack Dorsey seems to have the CEO
of twitter.
He seems to think that it's a sort of
freedom from rather than freedom too.
So free speech on twitter.
It means freedom from conservatives,
freedom from different points of view,
and it plays into the safe space and
trigger warning culture that I know that
you and your listeners know no more than
enough about already.
Um,
it,
it's freedom from ever having to be
exposed to anything that might make you
feel uncomfortable.
Well,
that's not what freedom of speeches and
for him,
he needs to stop lying to users that the
twister is,
you know,
the free speech.
We have,
the free speech party.
It's very clear if you step off,
if you go off reservation on most of
these social networks,
you're going to be punished.
And facebook too,
by the way,
is teaming up with Angela Merkel in
Germany.
I think everybody knows it's now to
sensor perfectly reasonable mainstream
discussion from citizens who are
concerned about mass immigration into
the country,
about millions of people coming into
their country about the rape epidemics,
about all sorts of awful things that are
happening to young German girls.
Facebook won't let you talk about it,
you know,
just
prove that is true and that you're not
making this up.
I've had to make things.
Yeah.
But I have,
I have two instances where I have a
decent connection at facebook and I've
had two instances.
One where my former guest feisal site,
Almodovar,
who's been here twice,
who is from Iraq,
a refugee from Iraq who is now living in
the west and fight through his,
around his page got banned because
people didn't like that he was speaking
out against Islam,
Islam.
And then I had a group of atheists,
Muslims that their page got banned as if
it was hate speech.
So what you're saying,
I'm just given,
I just want people to understand the
real.
You're not just
do to everybody and they,
and they don't even can now about
violating their own sacred tenants.
Uh,
you know,
this identity Marion nonsense,
what you're sort of in a protected class
from a,
you know,
as far as liberals or consent.
If you're a woman or if you're gay,
if you're black or whatever.
Now,
there are universities that are there,
there are university students who are no
platforming,
black transsexuals,
because you know,
they get invited by Jews.
This stuff has become incidentally
happened last week and they got him up
and they don't mind.
They don't mind if you're gay or if your
brown skinned or whatever.
What they,
what they will not tolerate is diversity
of opinion.
You know,
the diversity of skin color has gone out
the window.
Now,
if you want to cry victim,
if you want to pretend you're an
oppressed class,
you'll get all sorts of clothes from the
left.
You'll get all sorts of rewards.
They don't care so much about that.
However,
what they really don't want,
what they are terrified of because they
can't fight it with facts,
is libertarian and conservative points
of view and that freedom from ever being
challenged on anything that freedom from
ever having to encounter something with
which you might disagree or something
that might make you feel uncomfortable
or something that might ridicule you is
the definition of freedom that has taken
hold on the left in America today.
And it is a poisonous.
It is,
um,
you know,
it is entirely antithetical to
democracy,
to the free and open exchange of ideas
to classical liberalism to,
um,
intellectually
that's what it is.
They're really,
that classical liberalism has really
been pushed aside where I'm at anymore,
but nobody really understood.
Nobody even knows that it exists.
I think the university is it
speak up.
I mean,
you know,
I,
I'm on my tour at the moment of
universities and the thing that has
amazed me is the extent to which the
faculty at these universities don't just
refuse to expose their students to
different points of view.
They don't just ridicule conservative
points of view.
They don't even know about them.
Uh,
you know,
the,
it's been for awhile,
fairly well known that the number one
textbook economics textbook,
um,
in this country in America,
uh,
you know,
on set lists is Karl Marx,
right?
And say what you want about it.
It's kind of a conservative talking
point,
but it's becoming increasingly clear,
especially at liberal arts colleges that
don't have any sort of federal
regulations about,
you know,
the sorts of things that the government
doesn't get involved in.
What they teach and these liberal arts
colleges,
the professors don't even know
alternative points of view,
let alone teach their students when I go
to these colleges and I suggest that
perhaps you don't have to give 75
percent of your earnings away to the
government for them,
spend it on feminists dance therapy.
Perhaps you know,
the,
you know,
perhaps this wage gap stuff isn't real
after all.
They,
I mean,
some of the students look at me weird
like slack jawed horror shock,
surprise.
It's like,
it's like a revelation to them.
Um,
the fact that somebody might come and
actually ask for evidence based policy
and evidence based beliefs rather than
this sort of bizarre ideology that
they're being fed at the moment,
which is only really flourishing because
of the safe space culture and the
trigger warning culture because it can
never be interrogated because it can
never be challenged because it can never
be,
um,
uh,
it can.
Nope.
Nobody is allowed to say,
well,
what about this?
You know,
um,
you,
you're suggesting that women get paid,
blah,
blah.
What about this?
The economics.
Don't say this by you,
by Milo.
Showing up to a college and saying a
couple things.
You're not.
I've never heard you incite violence,
right?
I've never heard you call to,
to hurt anyone directly.
You're saying things you're even
admitting.
I mean,
I think it's clear that you're admitting
that you do sometimes go over the line
of what you even think is proper.
Sort of to just elicit a response from
it isn't true,
but I'll certainly use provocative
language.
Um,
I mean,
I don't know.
I'll go up and I'll make black dick
jokes and I'll do all that kind of stuff
because I,
we're still allowed to make jokes in
this guy at that.
Well,
no.
Well you say that,
but now for to say that,
but Chris Rock Seinfeld,
all these comedians,
comedian,
and you don't understand this,
you know,
comedians like gay people that we spoke
about this in the last,
the last time I was here,
so canaries in the coal mine with this
stuff.
They understand the threats to create a
freedom before everybody else.
And No,
you can't make jokes in this country
anymore.
You can't make this job.
You cannot make innocent jokes in this
country anymore without running serious
risk of professional professional damage
and social censure and if you are a
public figure making a joke about
anything to do with race or gender or
anything,
you know you are at risk.
You're at risk from one of these,
one of these mobs coming off soon.
You know,
it's so funny because I'm obviously as
big of a free speech proponent as could
possibly exist and I think sometimes
that I'm tweeting something and I'm
thinking,
man,
if someone looks back on this in 10
years,
if this ideology,
if this leftist ideology keeps taking
thrown in jail in 10 years,
they're going to go well because
there'll be a law passed and said,
well,
10 years ago you tweeted that,
this and that and but I prefer to take a
more courageous approach to it and you
know,
the,
the proper response to outreach to our
rich cultures to be outrageous.
Right?
I prefer to double down.
If somebody says that they find
something offensive,
I will tell a joke twice as bad because
words don't hurt you.
You get a certain leash though.
Being British and gay,
I think it gives you a certain leash.
That was,
I like to think it's my.
It's my,
my hard work and a and fact based
argument,
a reason,
but recognize it's probably got more to
do with my good looks hair,
my hair.
No,
but you.
You do get a certain leash because of
your persona.
Now you've built that yourself,
so I don't mean that to discredit you in
any way.
And I know how hard you misleading word.
I've always been this ridiculous.
Didn't make you see.
I feel that the regressives made me like
this.
You feel you were born this way.
I was born ridiculous.
No,
I was born with it.
We're forcing ridiculousness upon you
because you have to make a point to the
crazy people that you have to try to
live with.
So.
All right.
Let's back up a little bit because I
want to talk a little bit more about the
social media companies themselves.
So you've made a good point about
twitter.
I mean there's no doubt that twitter,
we know that their shadow banning right.
Whereas people are popular.
People who say unpopular things suddenly
just don't show up in time,
wondered about people wondered about
this for awhile and I was the one that
broke the story because I had
confirmation from multiple people that
they work with very closely saying
twitter admitted,
yes,
we absolutely do do this.
We white list certain accounts so they
show up in the top of search results and
we blacklists some accounts.
So they jumped and you know,
this is not in question.
It's not a,
it's not a conspiracy theory of many
things on twitter.
Feel a bit like conspiracies.
Yeah.
Oh,
the band under the Hashtag.
And sometimes they might have done and
sometimes they've definitely didn't.
And who now I'm pretty sure they're
fiddling around with the regressive left
tash that they offered.
Um,
there's no question whatsoever because
they've admitted to two sources that
have come to us that we've,
we've,
we've published as a result,
you know,
they've admitted that they actively
manipulate their network in order to
favor people they like and often our
business partners,
but it's also people that they're like
ideologically.
So that really is 1984 kinds of stuff
for what we can have in 2016.
This type of manipulating either we're
talking definitely entitled to do it.
You just need to stop lying about it.
It's perfectly entitled to do.
If they want to run their network like
that,
fine.
The business will collapse.
The Conservatives are all even and most
liberal is actually also want to win on
the merits.
They don't want.
They don't want the game to be rigged
right there.
I mean,
I like to think most liberals,
a nice,
decent,
honest people who would like to win on
the merits.
I think most don't.
I haven't seen much evidence of that in
the last 10 years.
We will get hijacked.
I really am a firm.
I mean I see what's happening.
Haven't been hijacked.
You see that I have so many friends like
this and you're all idiots.
That's very clear.
Movement has left you behind.
There's no space,
no space for free speech on the left and
not just this bit of the left.
Most of the left you are in a tiny slice
on the left of people who still care
about reason,
rigor,
fact scrutiny and free speech and there
is no place for you on the left anymore,
so you need to come over and you need to
just just just given,
given I understand that you were going
to do the whole like I'm a liberal who
believes in free speech thing is good
marketing,
but give it up there seriously because
there's nothing for you on the left
anymore.
Well,
but that's why they don't even like
cute.
They don't like you.
They decided now that if you're gay but
you're white and a man,
the white man bits of the privileged gay
bits and now they're telling us that
our.
Now they're telling us that our sexual
preferences are racist.
Like if you've gotten your grindr
profile,
I could prefer white guys.
And I wrote,
I wrote a column on this.
It says,
the only job I've ever had censored.
My employers are wonderful,
so supportive and brilliant.
They let me write whatever the hell I
want with it.
This is the one that they said,
are you sure you want to do that?
I sort of what my grindr profile says
blackstone is that racist.
Uh,
although of course I wouldn't put blacks
only because that might put some people
off.
I'll do words that create the same
effect,
you know,
like don't contact me if you are under
seven inches and you know,
your dad is.
So again,
that was the energy,
the energy that they're now policing our
sexuality,
you know,
and you know,
you straight white gay men.
Well,
well it's the straight white bit.
That's the problem.
So that the.
Sorry,
the white gay men and difficult to keep
up with it.
It's a lot.
So is that.
So that's sort of what I see with this
ideology.
I know you're going to work this next
hour you're going to be working,
but when I see the problem is,
is that there's never an end to it.
So they sort of used gays to get a
little more power and now they're done
with.
Well,
you've now that you're saying right now,
realize that what we discussed in our
last show you were completely wrong and
I was completely right to and I said
that you were part of the problem that
you had bought out into this sort of
domestication of homosexuals.
The liberals just want to plunk you down
in gay areas there.
Where do you live?
You lived at Gary.
Daniel,
of course,
of course you do a,
you know,
plunk you down with your dog and your
husband and you know,
you're nice lighting,
nice domestic life and now they've got
you.
Now they've got you.
You'll be a democrat voter forever.
It's easy.
Like they can move onto the next group
and then just got you in the bag and the
whole point we talked about last time
about sort of dissident.
I'm gay culture,
but the most exciting people being the
free thinkers.
I think you're now starting to realize I
was right,
which is lovely.
Very gratifying for me.
Wonderful.
Oh,
I realized that the left leg,
he was six months ahead.
Again,
we'll look.
I realized without question that the
left has lost its mind as to the point
that it's a slice like this.
I do think that the fight that my side
of this on the left is starting to wake
up in big numbers,
so I don't think we all have to somehow
defect to you guys just yet as much as
you'd like to you guys.
I mean,
I'm not a Republican.
I mean I'm,
I,
I'm British for stock.
Might even vote here.
I'm a daddy supporter,
but yeah,
we're going to get to your daddy called
trump daddy.
Everybody knows this now.
I'm so just wrapping up the social media
stuff and free speech related to these
companies.
If these companies are run by these
social justice warriors and it really
does seem like,
look,
I don't want to lose my twitter
verification so I don't get great lose
it.
You're going to go.
So look,
I don't want to lose that and I and I
don't want to be banned on facebook and
I,
you know,
we put our videos up on youtube
obviously I saw last week or two weeks
ago.
There was this organization that does
translations from Arabic,
uh,
and they,
all they do is translate what moms are
saying and mosques or telling about
killing all the Jews and killing all the
gates and they got banned for hate
speech.
All they do is translate the hate speech
enough want you should know what the
Muslims are saying.
They don't want you to know what's
happening in these mos because if people
knew about it,
they might be less happy with this.
You know,
this huge influx of immigration.
They might be less happy about having
their own perfectly reasonable points of
view.
Censored and mischaracterized as hate
speech.
I mean this is what the left does.
It mischaracterizes ridicule and
criticism is abuse and harassment.
It can mischaracterize is perfectly
valid,
ordinary anxieties that regular people
are justified in having as hate speech.
I'm looking at on the world now and I'm
thinking people like Tommy Robinson from
the edl,
he's been on the show,
Brian and I'm thinking there was some
things he said in the nineties and
whatever.
It was fun too much and the violence is
obviously obviously unacceptable,
but I'm listening to him now and people,
oh,
Tommy Robinson has racist pig.
I'm just gonna say now I can't find
anything to disagree with.
I can't find anything to disagree with
it in his speech when he went to Oxford
University,
mapped out his,
his life and what he,
how he saw his community changing and
how he saw the police.
Uh,
either hamstrung or actively lying about
it.
The government lying about it,
the media lying about it.
And all this stuff is now playing out in
social media.
And the scary thing about these
companies is that they are totally,
totally.
They are in lockstep with government,
facebook,
Germany,
lockstep with,
with,
uh,
with Merkel,
there video of,
of Zuckerberg,
Mark Zuckerberg,
you know,
twitter here,
locks.
They have meetings all day everyday with
this,
you know,
with,
um,
with government officials at lockstep on
this stuff.
Um,
I don't know what they're going to do
when,
when daddy gets into the White House,
but,
um,
but no,
it's terrible.
I should tell people,
when you say data,
you're talking trump,
just for the people that don't know all
your lingo,
everyone just yet they're referring to
trump will get to for I'm referring to
the God emperor trump it as the God
emperor and his incoming trump and
riker.
So I've realized if I accomplish nothing
else with you while sitting here,
I want you,
we've accomplished nothing so nothing
happens over night,
but I want you to at least make the
different distinction between when you
talk about the left and leftists versus
liberals,
you know,
really don't see those.
I don't want to make that distinction.
So you just think I'm just the outlier
of this situation.
But yeah,
I know.
I know I'm the outlier,
but he does $50,
million viewers.
Then I will,
whatever the hell numbers they have this
wheel.
If someone's people didn't come from
nowhere,
that's what the left is,
that you don't belong there and I
wouldn't call those people liberal.
It's more of a work of linguistic
history that the American left,
his called is called the liberal
movement because they don't believe in
liberalism.
The not classical,
but I'm sorry,
you know,
arguing over words like the left likes
to do isn't going to change the fact
that the entire left side of the
American political spectrum has gone mad
and if you,
you know,
you just can't in good conscience vote
Democrat and if you've,
you know,
if you don't believe in any of this
stuff,
if you want us to be able to have
discussions like this,
not just on your show,
but on the national news and in the
pages of the newspapers,
if you believe in that,
you cannot vote Democrat.
Well that's where these motherfuckers
have caught me.
They've really pushed me into a corner
here because everything,
all the,
all the free speech stuff,
right?
You know,
fighting against the ideology,
secularism,
all of that stuff.
That's right.
That's my stuff.
That's the stuff I really care about.
The crazy on the left.
So the left right now is crazy on this
stuff I care about most.
And I say that as someone that has
never,
not voted democratic ever.
And here we are so that now,
as I've scared you is.
This is the Segue,
the table.
There's a table where.
Okay.
Yeah,
so let's,
let's move on to trump.
So when,
when you were here in October,
I think you were just starting to get
behind the trump movement,
but at that time was at that time I
wasn't sure at that time he had had
maybe had one or two debates.
Everybody was still saying this was a
joke.
I think I was still saying it was a
It's clearly not a joke.
And what does it was that great
Beaumont,
like no one's loving now.
Actually we all,
you know,
generation trump are having a great
time.
Yeah.
You guys are having a great time.
Where the only people who all who all
laughing.
No,
I did your show and I did Joe Rogan,
who's also great.
I did his show and at that time I was
like,
well,
do I really want trump in the White
House on North shore?
Right?
I'm sure about that,
but I'm enjoying the spectacle.
My views have evolved.
The evolution.
Well,
you see,
I care about all the things that you
care about and I see the best way to
accomplish what we collectively want to
throw our lot in with,
with the politician that doesn't know,
like the rest of them,
that it terrifies the rest of them.
I mean,
the prospect of a trump candidacy,
the prospect of a trump presidency
terrifies not just liberals or
conservatives to,
because he's,
he threatens to blow apart the political
consensus to blow apart.
I mean,
fiscal crisis in particular,
if you believe as I do,
that is one of the great cancers of
public life.
There's nobody better situated to have
fun with that than trump.
If you believe that,
um,
you know,
not just the left but the right has lost
it's way too.
If you believe that,
let's,
let's do one of these at a time.
So if you believe that you want to just
blow the system apart,
you're the first thing that you
mentioned.
I'm an engine of chaos.
I think they're all.
Am I allowed to say you're in.
You can say whatever.
You know what I want.
So you're like the joker in Batman in
the movie,
right?
He just wanted to say that.
And then I stopped.
That counts.
So you want to burn.
So basically you would want to burn the
system.
See
Gop politicians telling CNN reports,
I think it was CNN,
you know,
the public doesn't pick the candidate.
Will we pick the candidate?
I just think to myself,
you deserve to know these people don't
like the public.
They don't like their own electorates.
And the Republican Party has become as
hostile to its own base as,
as liberals have always been.
They started talking about their own
base in the same way that liberals
always have.
Um,
you've got National Review publishing
disgusting things about why white
working class Americans just awful.
These people aren't going away.
Uh,
and these people are angry and
frustrated and it was interesting about
trump,
I think has captured the imagination of
a huge swathe of the population,
um,
from what you might call traditional
trump supporters.
You know,
the,
the veterans,
you know,
the white working classes who feel very
disoriented by this new globalized world
and very concerned about mass
immigration for wage reasons,
for cultural reasons too,
and they're right to be considered.
Those are just the,
that,
both of those,
both of those accounts but,
and the question I always get asked,
and I don't mean to disrespect that,
that group at all because that group is,
is,
is my readership and I love them when
people ask me what is smart people about
trump,
what they mean is,
what if people like us for trump,
you know,
we're not because we're not supposed to.
Right?
We're not,
not you.
I mean obviously not you,
but why do people like me vote?
Why would I vote trump?
Why do you know media types?
Fuck trump.
And the,
the answer to that is he represents the
best hope we have of smashing political
correctness apart of breaking open.
You know,
all of the taboos,
the things stuff you're not supposed to
say,
and allowing real debate to be had.
Again today.
It is impossible in America to have an
honest discussion about the wage gap,
about whether or not men and women get
paid different amounts of money and we
won't get into that today,
but what we can't use radical Islam as a
more relevant example.
You can't have an honest discussion.
You would lose your job or you wouldn't
get it back.
You'll never get a comment.
National newspaper,
the overton window is so narrow and
pushed so far to the left,
um,
that something big has to happen.
A big tumultuous event needs to happen.
And I believe that that event is a trump
presidency because I think it will
destroy the Republican Party that will
never win another election,
which is what I want.
And I think the same thing will happen
on the left too with,
you know,
the Sanders Hilary kind of tearing
comment on the left.
I have what I want.
Yeah,
and I think this might be what you want.
What I want is a source of new political
realignment on Libertarian authoritarian
lines rather than left and right.
And I want a new consensus to emerge.
A disaffected liberals,
classical liberals.
You know,
dissident minorities like gays,
you know,
a small state conservatives,
libertarians,
people who basically want to be left
alone,
people who believe that government
should have some limited functions,
but our culture should not be policed on
language,
not be police.
We should be able to do be,
say,
think and act exactly as we pleased.
Now,
I believe there is a majority in this
country who would get behind that sort
of cultural insurgency.
And this election is the first election
in American history that has been fought
not on foreign policy and on economics.
It's being fought culturally.
It's been edited and it is being a,
it has been excited.
It has been stirred up by a cultural
figure by reality TV star,
by a,
you know,
an American icon.
Um,
I've come around to believe that
actually having trump in the White House
would be wonderful and if he finds
himself in the White House and isn't
able to achieve very much inside of me
is going to daddy's gonna build a wall
and that is going to fix trade.
And that's gonna happen.
If then things start locking up because
he's got a noncompliant,
you know,
left and right in all the various
machinery of government.
I don't see that as a particularly bad
thing.
One of the best presidents in history
was coolidge.
Why?
Because he did absolutely nothing.
Um,
you know,
having some,
having like a cooler with bluster would
be no bad thing and all of the
criticisms that are normally leveled at
trump,
all of the stuff that people say
clownish and his populous,
I don't see those things.
Uh,
as intrinsically I'm anti presidential.
I mean,
in fact,
presidential material is very much in
the eye and the eye of the beholder.
And clearly there are enough Americans
who do believe,
um,
that,
that trump is presidential.
What's really exciting about trump is
that he is to the same in the same way
that we are,
I think.
And I definitely am.
I'm trump is a direct creation of the
progressive left.
He has been brought about.
He exists because of the people that we
both hate.
So I'm with you.
There had been saying for a long time,
bullied and policed and and harangued
and hectored,
a name called for so long.
They've told people that they are
homophobes when they're not.
They're topical,
they're sexist when they're not.
they're racist.
When they're not there.
Tell people they're transphobic and they
don't even know what that means.
Yeah.
They'd be bringing out all the heavy,
heavy weapons here to bring the over
because I get this.
You're going to the.
This is exactly what I'd want to use the
left because I didn't want this to
happen.
Well,
it's too late now,
buddy.
So you either get on the train or you
know,
who cares.
Okay.
So what do you not see some risk.
Even if I grant you all of that and you
say a lot of them questioning in order
to seem to have seem to have grown too.
Even if I grant you all of that,
do you think that there is some risk
that by unearthing all of the ways we
speak to each other?
Again,
I say this as the most pro free speech
person there is.
I am definitely now seeing a real
current of racism rising up,
a real current of,
of really hating Muslims of really
hating Jews have really.
I mean,
I'm seeing it bubble up on social media.
I don't think you're misreading the
situation.
So.
So how am I misreading that?
Well,
uh,
oh,
are we not worried about this stuff
bubbling up isn't bubble.
It is,
but it's always been.
It's always there.
You know,
people have prejudices about people
sometimes there's prejudices.
All right.
Uh,
when I was speaking at rutgers,
somebody in one of the,
one of the students,
I said,
well,
you know,
there are studies that show that,
that white people think black people are
loud and obnoxious,
you know,
and that's racist and maybe that's a
cultural thing.
Black people do use language differently
and they just couldn't wrap their head
around the fact that,
so that a prejudice might be right now
it's what you do with that sort of
assumption or prejudice or whatever.
Um,
that the,
the masses.
Okay.
It may be that the two things to say on
this right,
one is just no hatefulness and racism
and sexism and homophobia left in this
country.
Really.
Most of the expression of that kind of
stuff is driven by the left.
Um,
when it,
it's sort of,
you know,
so you know,
they go,
they go looking for,
for homophobia.
They call around all these,
you know,
bakeries in the Midwest or whatever.
Finally they find somebody who says,
no,
we'd rather not do a lesbian wedding.
I'm like,
guys,
we found some homophobia.
Excellent.
You know,
they go all in on it.
It makes me want to go out and bash
queers when I say I'm so angry about it
because it's just such obvious bollocks.
Now the second thing,
and I,
you know,
when you police down like crushed
people,
it creates,
it creates exactly what you're claiming
that you are looking for.
And this is sort of kafkaesque for
bactrian cycle.
The left and the second thing,
we're also using it specifically to
attack Christians in this case,
right?
Because you wouldn't go to,
you don't see them going is the article
that are interested in the bigotry.
They don't care about fixing bigotry.
They care about hurting Christians and
ridiculing Christians.
That's all true to second thing is your.
You say you're seeing all this stuff
bubble up on social media at.
Well,
I'll.
Let me take the.
The ultimate example.
What remains the big taboo in society,
which is Anti Semitism,
right?
Most of the generation trump,
the outright people,
so people who like me,
they're not antisemites.
They don't care about Jews.
They May.
They may have some assumptions about
Jews.
They may have some prejudice about Jews
that the Jews run everything while we do
the Jews run all the banks.
What we do,
the Jews run the media.
you know,
I mean they're right about all that
stuff.
Now what you do with that is is the
issue,
but the reason they go on a parody,
but where to start with that,
so just go.
This is not intubate.
It's statistical facts.
Now the Jews are on most of the banks.
Jews,
Jews completely dominate the media.
Vastly disproportionately represented in
all of these professions.
That's just a fact,
isn't antisense antisemitic to point out
statistics.
Um,
but you know,
you seem to have you,
you know,
you've,
you've missed what,
what you agree with me on feminism,
like it's not sexist when statistics I'm
suggesting to you is not,
you know,
it's not antisemitic to point out that
these things are true.
Now the antisemitism on the Internet,
which is really important,
and I want people to understand this
because nobody seems to,
when Jonah Goldberg of now have a
national review,
whatever is bombarded by,
um,
you know,
these memes,
so like,
you know,
that whatever it is and you know,
antisemitic,
take a hike,
all this kind of stuff.
It's not because there is a gigantic
outpouring of spontaneous outpouring of
antisemitism from 22 year olds in this
country.
And what it is,
is the,
it's a mischievous dissident trolling
generation who do it because it gets a
reaction,
right?
That's been the case for young people
for generations.
It's just that now they have access to
things that really get under people's
skin and Internet scale economics.
And,
uh,
and,
you know,
viral dynamics and they can get to
people in positions of power and people
in positions of power keep biting and it
keeps taking the bait that,
you know,
look,
if you enjoyed that,
that sort of explain why.
This is what I said at the beginning of
the show that you're
sort of a micro trump to me because your
rise has been.
I know you want to think you're bigger
than trump,
but you're not.
No,
no,
no.
Everybody,
everybody has everybody's daddy to
somebody.
I'm very happy to trump to be a better
daddy and I'll be daddy to,
you know,
everybody else.
So.
But basically what you're saying is that
they're using,
they're just using the tools to get
people angry and then it causes another
reaction and then there's another
reaction and that is what it's trolling
and this is a direct response to the
language.
Policing is a direct response to people
being told they can't say things.
What you've got to know about the
millennial generation and,
and my friends run as young.
Okay,
okay.
Must have 13 year olds,
right?
These people don't know what the
Holocaust was,
they don't know.
They don't have any living relatives who
were,
who were in it.
They in many cases don't even really
remember nine slash 11,
you know,
they haven't lived through these big
traumatic events in world history that
just trolling and I've recognized that,
you know,
saying stuff about Jews gets on the
nerves of journalists and you can get
like.
It's like I've seen that guy on Fox
News,
he's on the TV and I just tweeted him
like this stupid you me,
but look at it and you know,
it's fun.
It's funny.
I find it funny because once you
recognize it,
it's not really about the Jew thing.
It's about trolling and provocation and
that's the thing that they've identified
works really well.
You begin to,
you when you look at it as sauce to make
more sense,
you're like,
yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Racism in this country.
I mean there is no KKK.
What is it like a few thousand members
left that we're constantly told what
supremacy is a problem.
There are no white supremacists.
There are no white nationalist.
They don't in the media,
they don't,
in politics,
they're nowhere,
you know,
that,
that have no purchase whatsoever,
no influence,
nothing.
If there is,
if there is a racially supremacist
movement,
it's black lives matter and it's very
well funded and it's massive and it gets
fawning coverage from the media.
There's no white supremacists movement
in this country and what trump
supporters primarily are reacting to is
being lied to and lied about for decades
by the establishment.
And for me,
trump has a very necessary correction to
that.
He is part of the Cultural Libertarian
movement that you and I,
uh,
I think both would identify with.
I would say he is the,
you know,
he is the ultimate icon of that
movement.
So basically you think that nobody else
could do this.
So I'm with you on a lot of this because
we do,
we do meet in that cultural libertarian
space and I get the language stuff and
I,
and I get what you're saying about the
antisemitism and all,
all of that stuff.
I really do.
I understand that.
And that's why I never attack people I,
you know,
I try not to fight with these people
when they're attacking me on twitter or
whatever they just want.
They don't care about the subject
because that because it's a 10 year old
kid,
right?
And the left uses this 17 year old cat
is rolling on the evidence that there's
some uprising of antisemitism,
of a nuts.
Well,
the left doesn't do with antisemitism
because they were okay with that.
They're fine with that,
but they'll do it with everything else
they do.
They certainly do it with anti feminism
stuff.
They suggest that there is this epidemic
of misogyny and they just find a random
tweet that's find all these tweets from
young
boys,
you know,
as to the young girls are congratulated
and applauded and encouraged to be
hateful toward men,
right when they,
you know,
they can get involved in kill all white
men,
hashtags,
masculinity.
So fragile.
I bathe in male tears.
You see teenage girls doing this stuff
and it's hateful and horrible and
they're going to be alone and miserable
forever because feminists have ruined
them.
Right?
Um,
when men do anything remotely similar,
you know,
they will come in for the most appalling
center.
They get suspended from school.
This is why girls,
we under their own names very often,
partly because they,
many of them are being trained into
being cry bullies.
They're being trained into being,
um,
you know,
to,
into putting provocations out there and
then squealing,
you know,
victimhood had been treated,
the girls are been taught that victim
button grievance culture is the way to
get what you want.
If you have no talent,
they're being trained in,
you know,
into,
um,
into all of this stuff.
Boys on the other hand,
very often are anonymous.
They like poll on that and like all of
these places where they can go let off
steam and get,
get all that boyishness boisterousness
out of their systems,
which is a perfectly normal,
healthy friends.
This is where they would also play video
games and get some of that aggression
out
and not a faggot and whatever.
I mean,
can you imagine what career I could have
made of,
you know,
being offended by the word Faggot,
I like,
no,
I wrote a column saying I want Faggot,
gay and queer to be in common usage.
That's how you take the power away from
these words.
If you believe they have power,
banning them when elevating them up
into,
into these,
you know,
these,
these taboos.
So I wrote this column,
I said,
but I want,
I want gay to be restored to its real,
like twits prestige.
Meaning it doesn't mean you know,
the real meaning of gays like crap,
rubbish,
Shit,
lame.
Hillary supporting immigrant mothers.
You know what I mean?
It's not in the dictionary yet,
but I'm sure they're getting around to
it.
You know,
this is why,
what gay to me,
when somebody says something stupid,
I want you to be able to say as gay or
stop being a faggot.
It doesn't mean anything.
These people aren't homophobes.
They do it because it gets to you.
And if there are any journalists
watching this,
please just learn this lesson.
Well,
it does show you how pervasive the
ideology is,
this controlling ideology,
because I see even now when I'm with
just some of my gay friends who are
supposed to be the most over the top and
not politically correct and all that and
actually be the politically correct
system.
But.
So that's what this goes to what I was
saying earlier,
that no way this ideology,
what it wants is not you because it
doesn't want you as the individual at
once you as the collective and then,
well,
he wants you as the identity as the
identity,
right?
So you're black or you're gay or you're
a trainee and he wants to put you in
that bucket and tell you what you're
supposed to believe about things and
tell you how to get what you want.
Even if you're not pair to work and you
have no skills because you can just
pretend to be offended about things and
you'll get on TV.
Um,
yeah,
they want you as that they want you as a
bucket.
And Gay gay men have fallen for this
hook,
line and sinker.
It really fucked up.
But fortunately there is an awakening in
the gay community,
there was something happening and there
was something happening among gay people
and I've noticed it identify antics and
I've noticed it in on social media,
there's something with gay,
so they're beginning to recognize the
left is not their friend.
They're beginning to rediscover the
virtues.
When we were talking in the last show
and I said,
you know,
one of the great things about gay life
is you can be,
you can be outrageous and diff different
and you can to topple out of a club on a
Monday afternoon,
like dragged off your face and you know,
with the cock and every orifice you can
do whatever.
You can do whatever you want.
And it's,
that's it.
It's that bit of gay life that creates
all of the arts and artists and
inventors and genius is why we're so
overrepresented and all the people that
shoves society forward,
right?
That's the kind of gay life that I
liked.
celebrate.
That's the kind of gay culture I think
is valuable and gay people.
So until we discovered this,
because that's as the left is not their
friend,
that feminists don't have their
interests at heart,
uh,
that in fact there's an,
they're fundamentally hostile to many of
the many of the things that make being
gay.
Great.
So for the,
for these guys,
for,
for gays,
lesbians,
whatever,
when they see the left defending Islam,
Islam and they go,
wait a minute,
I could be that these people want to
throw us off of roofs and put us on
cranes in 11 countries.
It's like,
what are you doing?
And then for some reason the leftists
feel the need to defend this idiot's.
Yeah.
So let's,
I mean,
how can you,
how can you support this?
How can you support this?
I mean,
you know,
they want what they want is for us to
expect us to believe that above gay
people,
above women,
above blacks,
I'm in the blanks,
is the worst thing,
right?
I mean,
they actually,
you know,
there's one group of people in this
country who are genuine grievances who
to whom something is still owed.
And that's the black community,
right?
There is a legacy from slavery.
I don't happen to believe that black
lives matter is the honest because I
think it's hateful and divisive and the
only real result of black lives matter
is black cities in flames.
Wait,
let's not gloss over that because people
are gonna are gonna.
Try to go after what you just said.
You're saying that the,
that the black community does have
legitimate grievances of course were
brought here by and large as slaves of
course.
And then did anybody ever suggest
otherwise?
I think a lot of people would say,
Oh,
if you're against black lives matter,
you're against.
Nobody's done more for the black
community than me.
I'm normally on went back.
But um,
the,
the issue is that the issue is very
straightforward.
You know,
black lives matter is,
hate is a hate for supremacy
organization.
I'm in so far as it's organized at all
it is,
is it's a movement of black supremacy
and it's a bad thing.
But this is what the law,
you know,
this is what the left likes to do is to
find people.
I forgot what we were talking about
bringing this all back to trump.
So what.
I haven't heard you say is anything
related to policy,
but before I even let you answer that,
I think what you're just saying is it's
completely irrelevant.
That's what you're saying,
that this movement has nothing to not
political movement in that direction.
There's nobody to take trump's place
after.
Right?
If trump became president via via all of
this stuff,
all of this cultural stuff,
he's a great president.
He's B.
He's creating.
It's you.
Your vp was creating a culture.
I want to honor you for a second.
You would be a good price.
Would be a fantastic.
Can you imagine?
I bet you feel like answering a
questions today.
I'm going shopping.
Put your comments in the box.
See you later,
but what you're talking about is a
cultural revolution,
not a political revolution,
so that's interesting because Bernie
who's talking a lot about flip the
system and our system's corrupt and
money and politics,
the same thing.
He's talking about a political
revolution and basically you're saying,
forget that.
Yeah.
That's just because he's an idiot and
he's 20 years out of date.
That would have worked before when
people were upset about economics,
upset about foreign policy and politics
and you want to work 10 years ago,
the Iraq war.
Now this war is cultural.
There's a cultural war and as any one
candidate for president fighting this
war culturally and it's trump,
he doesn't care too much whether he is
occasionally inconsistent on policy
because he understands that nobody else
does either.
And he's very sad.
That's a sad thing.
Sad,
sad about.
No,
no.
I studied politics set over here.
Why don't you study politics,
you know,
goals once he's made two very clear
statements.
One is that he wants to build a wall and
that's emblematic of what he believes
about immigration and illegal
immigration in particular.
They can come over as he says,
but they've got to come over legally.
Um,
which in and of itself isn't racist,
right wing racist about that.
Well,
people keep Mexicans out of the race
that way.
On that.
Yeah.
Well,
his Hispanic,
because you Americans have this or
Hispanic,
what you try to,
you try to invent like divisions between
people so that anything anyone says
about anyone can somehow be called
racist,
Hispanics away on that.
That I'll bring the chart next time.
I don't want to get bogged down.
This is a new thing or the thing,
you know,
you people,
you people make these rules up.
We just have to live in it and live it.
They live in your world.
Now,
of course it's not racist if,
what he's,
what he's saying is that there is um,
you know,
and in fact of course is his concerns
about immigration benefit the black
community more than anybody else because
when you Hispanic immigrants come in,
it's black wages.
They depressed not,
not,
not primarily necessarily white wages.
By the way,
Barack Obama said something to that
effect when he was running for president
the first time.
Yes.
He's done so much for the black
community.
I mean,
racial,
racial harmony in America now.
Such a lovely thing.
Eight years of Obama.
Don't we all just love each other?
After eight years of Obama now he's been
the has been the most disastrous
president for blacks in.
Is that.
Is that Obama's biggest failure then
that he came in with the political and
cultural revolution,
right?
It was political and it was cultural.
It had both elements to it,
but what he's going to exit with
regardless,
everything comes,
everything is worse and everything is
worse as a result of him will the
economy.
Right?
The American economy is better right now
than it was.
Well,
okay,
but give me silica.
Gays can get married.
I know you're not a big proponent.
I wish they would stop.
I know,
but I wish they would name a bit
quality.
Getting married.
We're going to ask your group and they
don't work as hard because they will.
Interesting.
Oh No.
All of that come of our Michael Cook for
you.
I thought sake,
but I know you're furry quality so I
know you're okay with ish.
Ish.
So is that really his failure that at
when he leaves this thing,
after eight years,
what could be ushered in after,
and not that it's purely his fault,
but what can be ushered in after is
going to be a complete flip of the
system.
I,
I don't know if that sounds good.
That sounds good to you.
So it's not a failure.
Well,
no,
I mean I,
I live in exciting times when pretty
much everyone in the country wants
establishment to suffer.
Pretty much everyone in the country
hates journalists,
hates politicians,
hates the,
you know,
the more they find out about what their
kids are being taught at college.
Largely thanks to me,
I think,
but hate that too.
And we live in exciting times.
People want to tear this system apart.
They want to rebuild the system in a
different way.
I've suggested that.
I'd quite like to do it along
authoritarian libertarian lines because
I think it makes more sense the way
people communicate these days and
people's priorities.
I think people are more interested in
culture than,
than economics selection.
Um,
that's the sort of realignment I want to
May look very different.
Um,
I,
what I like about daddy like about trump
is that he is introducing an element of
realness and an element of fun and
mischief into an arena in which into,
into public life,
which is an arena in which there has
been so little freedom and joy for so
long that is unnecessary correction,
you know,
so that can't make jokes on TV anymore.
Life isn't fun anymore.
As a journalist,
like if I were a regular journalists,
try and have a,
not a regular journalist because I work
at a wonderful place.
Breitbart with lets me do,
you know,
outrageous and crazy things.
And obviously now I'm becoming this sort
of media figure I can.
I've got more licensed to,
to,
to do stone.
So if I'm a regular journalist Ip,
so,
and,
and I mean,
I know,
do you know,
dozens,
the minor.
It doesn't say it's a miserable life.
They can't say you can't tell the truth,
you can't tell facts because somebody
somewhere will get upset.
You know,
you can't say facts was,
journalism has become now more about
virtue signaling to your fellow
reporters than telling the truth about
what's actually happening.
Right?
So I got into a big fight with a
buzzfeed guy this week because they
wrote a piece about the regressive left
claim,
sweet claim you fall with this guy had a
soft spot for Joe Bernstein,
but I don't even want to give him any
extra cred,
right?
Let's not.
We don't have to waste any set.
And even name him the left as you say,
this is what the lab.
So I left the voldemort left us.
So you want an.
Somebody is wrong.
Talk about it.
Will shine the light on guy your,
your progressive,
your natural progressive tendencies just
slipped out.
Alright.
So this guy,
you want to put him under the credit.
Why you sent this Guy Bernstein from
buzzfeed.
Joe Bernstein.
There you go.
I want the.
I want the full light of scrutiny on
every one I disagree with so that other
people can see their wrong too.
So this guy basically wrote a piece on
Joel.
Joel Bernstein wrote a piece on buzzfeed
this week.
You don't,
you want to call me a cultural
librarians.
I'm just not that because I'm a cultural
libertarianism and because he's never
got the balls to say.
What do you really mean that about both
your librarian.
I thought it was great,
right?
Yeah.
Well you just went straight back to the
fucking reference section.
So Joe Burns OPA and stained from busboy
and gives feedback on basically saying
that,
uh,
you know,
my guy as in Sam,
Harrison,
a few others will mark,
you know,
created this regressive lessons.
But really what the regressive left
thing is about.
It's about alt right.
Hate.
And those are the people that have made
it a thing where I know and every
instance of it on twitter and everywhere
else is because of the few people that
are left on the left,
like myself who has tried to make it
into something.
Now again,
that sounds like insider baseball stuff,
but it's about that.
But he wrote a piece about me that was
wrong to what I did notice.
You have like,
you know,
Oh,
don't mention his name.
Well,
I did instead was,
I challenged them to debate me.
I said to bait me,
I'll give you $5,000.
Rock up one hour,
debate me.
You're wrong.
Prove,
prove,
prove your case.
Scurried into a whole silence,
carried into a hole.
They actually went up to $6.
Now,
to be fair to Joe Bernstein of Buzzfeed,
buzzfeed takes at Bernstein on twitter.
Go.
Okay.
To be fair to him,
since then we've,
we've worked together and,
and you know,
when pcs he's broken some news for me
and,
and he's been,
um,
he's been very fair and very reasonable.
Um,
but he was wrong about that and refused
to debate because he knew he couldn't
defend his arguments.
Uh,
the same thing I think applies with you
too.
I don't think he'd be able to defend his
position on that piece,
which was obviously garbage.
Well,
I took it out and they all got hundreds
and thousands of responses to him and he
ignored all of it.
Of course.
I don't think he'd show up to debate you
on that,
but you should,
if you lend me the fact that,
well I won't need it because I'd win the
debate.
So that's.
No,
you can't have any money but it goes to
the Shapiro now.
Why do we still have money with guests
on your show?
The ostium,
how much he was worth,
how much you earned or something like
that.
Well,
I wanted him as a,
uh,
as a one percenter to,
to tell people how much you want a
number I wanted.
I said I give you a number.
I'd have.
No he didn't,
but he said he's in the over 400 K I
guess situation.
Who isn't?
Go ahead.
We're really foster right to Laurie.
Eric and I'll make a note of that.
Alright.
So all of this stuff,
so,
so trump,
you're laying out a decent case of
putting all this stuff together.
But let's talk quickly about the
pushback from the establishment because
I think that's an under reported piece
about this that the establishment has
tried very hard to push back on this and
they are rolling out.
Mitt Romney lost guy who lost last time
is supposed to be the same,
right?
You roll out,
you know Lindsey Graham goes from failed
candidate.
He endorses another failed candidate,
but another like they just roll out the
same guys and then if you watch the
debates,
and I've watched 90 percent of them
trump systematically,
whether you agree with him or not,
systematically destroys these people.
I mean he embarrassed your voice
actually is worsening system
systematically destroys these people.
I mean here he seems to have no
particularly a consistent approach to
destroy.
Let me just rocks up.
Cracks a few jokes and tell slip.
Tell tells it how it is.
It's actually unsystematic,
which is even more of an indictment on
the establishment.
How delmia,
how stupid they are.
They think we're also the only thing
where it is.
It is.
So do you think if they had put the
establishment had found someone that
basically knew who he was,
had decent conservative principles.
So it's not.
I guess the closest to that could have
possibly been jeb,
but the bush name was so damaged and he
was also a terrible candidate.
He's a classic cook.
Yeah.
He's saying he's,
as we say on the Internet.
So coq one have you defined cock because
I see this popping up all that.
Well,
so I like this word and all the rest of
the conservative media don't because
they know it describes them.
Um,
and it is.
Well.
So I know that you probably don't watch
any pornography anymore because since
you've been with your partner for
ceremonial life,
more like a lesbian.
Go ahead.
Just,
just sexless knew about carpet.
Well,
I'm about to socal about phone.
That's what.
Okay.
So if you were a porn viewers are not
particularly important for you.
Yeah,
if you were a point of view,
um,
he didn't want that to be a shorter.
Doubled down on that one.
If you were a porn viewer,
you may be familiar with genre of porn
in which sort of white husband watches
his wife get rammed by a large black man
that's not always a large black man at
sometimes at this,
whatever this is,
this cockiness is cuckold tree from
Shakespeare and chaucer to where.
And it wasn't anything to do with race.
I don't think it's specifically to,
the rest is just sort of become a bit of
a ponder them as well,
but anyway,
the idea is it's sort of,
it's people who have sold out and
enjoying watching their wife,
their country.
They're people that are supposed to look
after whether its readers in the case of
journalist stories,
uh,
constituents,
the case of politicians getting fucked
by,
um,
uh,
some scarier external force,
whether it's radical Islam or mass
immigration or whatever.
Now it's metaphoric,
it's a metaphor,
you know,
um,
and it's a perfectly good,
uh,
and perfectly fun,
vibrant sort of metaphor.
I quite like it and I use it myself.
I think it's fun and it's,
it's very,
uh,
of course,
conservatives now,
the conservative establishment,
which is basically gotten along with all
of the tenants of the left and now look
to the left for approval.
Is it okay?
Can I say this as this racist,
sexist than the right,
the right way.
Establishment.
So terrified of being seen as racist,
that they sort of distanced themselves
from this word in case or any sort of
racial connotations whatsoever.
No,
no,
we can't go to jail.
Anyway,
Jeb has a bit of a perfect example of
this.
You know,
somebody who is weak,
uh,
who is it?
There's no sense with with Jeb Bush,
there was never any sense,
and I feel that,
sorry he's gone now because it was kind
of Nice Guy,
but there's no sense he would ever stick
up for his country.
And the one thing you can't say about
trump is that he wouldn't stick up for
America.
Now,
you may disagree with some of his
prescriptions,
but he clearly loves the country.
He clearly wants America to be great
again.
Now that's a very provocative slogan.
Make America great again.
You know the,
again,
has that something was lost,
right?
As a,
there's a,
there's a big,
there's a big shocking claim in there,
one that politicians don't normally
make,
that the country is not great.
It's a,
in fact,
is this sort of thing you normally hear
from liberals if we're honest,
you know,
Obama clearly doesn't like this country
very much.
Um,
we generally hear it from conservatives.
Now there's something very exciting
going on with that.
All right,
with this candidate is something very
exciting,
all that terrifies establishment,
but what I've,
what I've realized,
which I think is really interesting is
that the trump has illustrated that the
concerns of the elites,
the concerns of the establishment,
the concerns of journalists and
politicians and the people who run our
lives are so alien from ordinary people
care about that they can't even argue
against him and it resonate with the
public.
I mean,
let's take for example something that
you and I both care about.
The First Amendment free speech,
freedom of the press.
Trump has repeatedly suggested that he
would like to,
in some way control,
curtail the full freedoms of the press.
He would like just this week with the
Washington Post that he would like.
He would like to make it more.
I mean,
I think what he's saying is he wants to
strengthen defamation law,
right?
Bad News,
particularly for you even more than me.
Right?
Well,
is it because I don't lie about people.
I might say funny names.
Sometimes I might ridicule people,
but I don't lie about them.
Like the liberal press does every day.
Uh,
and the conservative press is just as
bad,
frankly.
They're all terrible.
I don't label people,
I don't make up facts about people.
Why would I worry about that?
I mean,
let's.
And let's look at it from an electrical
point of view,
right?
The public,
my head just went through the list of
all my liberal friends that lie
constantly,
publicly.
And that would suffer from this.
Right?
Exactly.
But I wouldn't know.
I've never,
I mean,
I say the most appalling things about
people,
but they're true.
Um,
and I've never been sued.
I might have an opposite.
So I've never been sued.
I mean,
you had imagined I'd be in court every
week,
you know?
No,
I don't get sued because there's a
difference between satire and joking.
But my fat,
I get my facts right.
Yeah.
I know there are,
there are people that are in court every
week and it's Gorka,
you know,
because they are so completely
unethical.
I mean,
so that's why the right felt that the
gawker thing with Hogan.
I know we're jumping all over the place.
That's why we enjoyed that.
Really loved.
But I saw it as a huge victory to
because we have places like awkward that
are just better literally trying to
destroy lives.
It's enough,
it's our private citizens anyway.
So I mean,
look,
the approach that we'll probably get
overturned on appeal,
and it's probably better that we don't
have an anti free speech precedent of
quite that nature because who knows what
kinds of sex tapes might be in the
public interest in,
in future.
Um,
two things is,
you know,
Pinellas County,
Florida juries don't set legal precedent
and it's going to get overturned.
So it'll be a pdf.
Anyway,
we'll see on the trump thing when he
says that the press are the bad guys.
Most people agree with him and this is
what the press doesn't understand
because they genuinely believe that they
are like some sort of true warriors for
Truth and justice.
They're not,
they're the bad guys.
The media in this country,
there's been a systemic industry,
white failure to tell the truth in this
country.
Well,
that's the normal situation under which
the government steps in and that's what
we do.
And it's oil.
That's what we do.
And it's some other kind of industry
when there is a system wide failure in
an industry banking,
for instance,
the government steps in and you know,
there's no reason why the first
amendment should insulate you from the
consequences of your actions if you go
out and deliberately mendaciously
knowingly lie about people in the key
word is knowingly or unknowingly.
Now the libel standardization
country.
Slippery slope though.
Well I wouldn't say the guy who gets
offended by Megan Kelly every other day,
God only knows what he thinks.
She's.
I think she's a hell of a lot more
triggered by him than he is by her.
Well that may be,
but he's on his way to becoming the most
powerful man on earth.
And she's just a reporter.
So I get what you're saying that if she,
if she's telling the truth,
then fine.
But what I would say,
telling the truth when you have the most
defend,
you know,
this guy who loves giving a fence,
but at the same time he's incredibly
thin skinned.
I don't think he's putting in libel law
know the president can't do that.
He's not.
He's not thin skinned.
At all,
he is
very smart game where he is illustrating
the absurdities of the fence,
taking an offense culture.
It's the thing is you've got to
understand about trump.
He didn't,
it didn't become a billionaire by
accident.
He's one of the smartest people in the
country,
you know,
he's so clever.
Everything he does is calculated.
Everything he does is designed to create
a particular effect or designed to,
uh,
to reach a certain goal.
So He'd been using bankruptcy to his
advantage.
I guess we proved who wouldn't,
I mean,
liberals love to do this bullshit,
you know,
of course,
of course he did.
It was a business man.
Of course he donated to Hillary.
So would I,
if I was running a business and there
was a strategic advantage,
I'd of course I go to a wedding,
I'd have her at my wedding or whatever.
That probably wasn't the best moment in
the first debate.
When he admitted it is,
of course you would.
It's so dumbed suggest otherwise.
The reason it offends people so much.
And the reason it surprised me so much
as most politicians have never done
anything other than politics.
So if they cozy up to a liberal,
it looks like treachery or it looks like
inconsistency.
It looks like ideological kind of
Tomfoolery.
While trump is never been in that
position,
it was a business man.
Of course he did these things,
but I want to just finish on the press
thing.
When trump says the press the bad guys
and he doesn't need speech all the time.
It gets some of the biggest cheers of
any of his stuff,
right?
When he says,
you know,
the press will never cover you.
The press will never turn around and
show these huge crowds.
All they'll do is if there's a protest,
they'll go down there.
There's a protest.
They go,
these guys are losers.
They're losers.
They get some of the big those lines.
Get some of the biggest applause.
It's that country hates the press.
And when the press is like Pearl,
clutching a about,
you know,
Oh,
fifth amendment or freedom.
While you misused to those freedoms,
you abused those freedoms.
You started lying about men lying about
race,
lying about immigration,
lying about Islam,
lying about everything that matters.
The press has lied systematically to
everyone about everything everyday,
all the time for decades.
It has abused its its privileges and you
know,
frankly,
I'm with trump and with the and with the
most,
with most Americans,
the press is part of the problem and for
them to stop poor.
Clutching about the first amendment.
Well,
you know what tough,
you abused this for decades.
Okay,
so when you take the power that the
press has a lot of power,
you take the power that the
establishment has on both sides.
A lot of power,
Democrats,
Republicans,
right?
You add all that up and now we still
don't have an election until November,
right?
We're in the end of March here.
Can this thing go forward without
getting much more violent?
That's sort of where I see this all
going.
And by the way,
I'll be very clear and say that I don't
know which way the violence is going to
come from.
I'm not going to say this.
Violence is gonna.
Just be honest.
It's going to come from.
So I don't think you should be such a
weasel.
I think you should say what you think
and I think,
I think you'd probably agree with me.
I was going to come from the left.
Just say it.
If it comes,
it goes down.
It's going to come from people
protesting.
Trump is not going to come from trump.
Protesters will look in the beginning of
the shift and just pick.
Just because he is his chief of staff
grab,
you know,
it can be a bit grabby.
Well of course he is the guy that trump
is.
Trump is so,
so much risk of being shot.
I'm like anybody else?
If there's somebody that's gonna get
assassinated in his country,
it's trump.
Is it any wonder the people close to him
a little bit cautious.
I don't get too much into that because
it involves,
you know,
other people that used to work with.
But yeah,
but you know,
if there's going to be violence on the
streets,
it is not going to come back.
So it will be the Bernie people.
I get that and that's not what.
That's ironic.
I tweeted the other day,
I like Bernie more than I like his
supporters,
which is really how I feel because yes,
I do agree.
If he goes out,
they will have been.
Yeah,
I know you're right.
But I just thought as a human,
I think he's a decent human being,
whether I agree with his policies or
not.
Well,
I just somebody,
somebody who makes excuses as to some of
the worst regimes in the world.
Somebody wants to,
wants to institute.
So it's to socialism,
which will make poor people poorer.
Somebody who wants to,
you know,
somebody who believes in the lies that,
uh,
the feminists,
we don't have to make this about him
now.
Don't just throw this stuff out.
Do you really mean that?
Do you mean not?
You think he's a nice person?
I think he's a nice person.
I think he believes it more hateful,
more unequal.
I think that.
Why do you say it's a nice place in what
he thinks?
The solutions.
So you don't believe in any of his
policies,
which you think is a nice person.
I think sometimes you can be a decent
person and BNB,
wrong policies.
We got some continual regardless if they
hold on,
so the person is.
I do agree that the violence will comes
from old and left wing,
that they're nice.
We don't do that with right wingers.
Why do we automatically assume just
because it's old and doddery and he's
got white hair and he sounds like a
crazy old lunatic.
Oh,
it must be a nice guy,
but I think really nice guy.
No,
he wants socialism in America.
That's poisonous political philosophy
that has made people suffer everywhere.
It has ever been tried everywhere.
Socialist.
I'm not pretending.
That's why Bernie Sanders is nice to get
it.
Why was he ever don't indicate the is a
decent.
Nice.
I could see it.
I've never seen any underpinnings of the
ideas that he talks about of trying to
make things more equal and trying to
change the system,
which is the exact same stuff to feeling
body weight,
but you're telling me that,
that the trump revolution,
a revolution that has a little something
to do with the feeling broke,
but I don't want to get totally
sidetracked on that.
It's not,
it's not a feeling.
It's not about feelings.
Well,
it has something to do with feelings.
You're telling me all these people,
and I'm agreeing with you on cultural
libertarianism is not about feelings.
Cultural Libertarianism is a response to
a feelings over facts.
In fact,
that the defining characteristic of
cultural libertarianism is a rigorous
adherence to evidence based policy
making in evidence based beliefs.
And,
and,
uh,
and uh,
a rigorous insistence on classical
liberalism.
It's got very little to do with feelings
scholars do with thumb because it's
often dressed up in a mischievous
package.
But the cultural libertarianism is a
reaction against the feelings based
arguments of the left.
The feelings makes arguments to the left
as perfectly lead by Bernie Sanders.
Bernie Sanders is the apotheosis of
everything you hate 'em,
but you still feel the need to call them
a nice guy because he's old.
Alright,
so without getting into a Bernie
offshoot here,
we're probably a little late for that.
I will grant you that if Bernie goes
down and the.
The narrative just continues.
Yes,
it will be his people.
I think that will be violent right now.
The media.
Then we'll try to blame it on the trump
people.
And that doesn't mean that there were no
trump.
People that are violent declaratives
conservatives are blaming it on trump.
I mean it was,
it cruise goes on cv the next day after
whatever st trump is responsible for the
violence.
Are they insane?
Okay.
So do they not realize why people are
voting for this guy?
They were voting for this guy because
you lie like that.
It's astonishing.
Anyway,
so at the top of the show,
what I mentioned was that just this
week,
trump was giving a speech in Arizona and
these protesters blocked the road.
These are not people.
They think they're doing something good
or they're doing something to stop
trump.
But,
but they're all there,
the rest is just taking a paycheck from
could whatever it is,
but they think that they're stopping
trump somehow or stopping him from being
heard are going to stop his movement.
But I think all they're doing is
strengthening him because they need to
have the basket of ideas because then
people turn on the wall.
Look what these people are doing.
The more these guys protest Daddy,
the more they show up and they're
violent.
It's just like my toxicologist,
you know,
there's these feminists smeared blood on
themselves rather than the block.
All the stuff.
Everybody saw the video.
Um,
you know,
everybody's suing.
Everybody thought the same thing.
God,
mine,
I must have a point.
That's what they thought.
And everybody thinks the same thing when
I'm,
you know,
when these protesters show up for trump
and they are the hateful,
angry,
violent,
divisive people.
And everybody there for trump is like
laughing.
They'll run their hats,
make America great again.
But it's not everybody.
You'll grant me that,
right?
It's not every day I saw a guy who was
screaming at some people go back to
Auschwitz.
You see some people go back to Africa,
I mean,
but yes,
every mood media is cherry picked a few
from this side versus the view from the
outside.
This is not,
this is not,
you know,
I'm just saying it's not,
it's not everybody.
I'm not giving the media and he greatly
here.
No.
Well,
I mean,
okay,
there.
I'm sure they're awesome supporters of
trump who are,
you know,
who are distasteful people like there
are supporters of Hillary.
Sure.
I think pretty much anyone who supports
her at this point just tasteful,
you know,
I think pretty much anyone support
sanders is just needs to,
needs to read a book.
Um,
you know,
needs to be educated,
needs to,
needs to reach puberty.
I don't know.
But the thing is about trump supporters
in my experience,
vast majority
of them,
whether they fall into the various
buckets of trump supporter,
you know,
whether it's the huge support he has in
the black community for all sorts of
obvious reasons because he's a very
aspirational,
you know,
American dream kind of candidate.
Um,
my colleague at Breitbart,
Sandy Johnson,
you know,
she says,
she says I love him,
I love him because when I see trump and
his name on a building and it got a name
on a plane,
I want that,
you know,
that element to it.
Yeah.
It's not,
well,
it's not just that some people are
offended by that kind of generalization,
but.
Oh,
there,
I said something that I thought you'd
be,
oh my God,
he said bling and now.
No,
no,
that was a bit much.
Maybe that's why they like me.
Uh,
no,
I,
um,
you know what I mean is,
you know,
that he's a,
he's a very classic aspirational
candidate for,
for black Americans,
also loved by the gay community.
Huge gay icon as a piece coming out in
Mike,
I think,
and another in vice soon.
I've given interviews for both of these
places on why so many gay people love
trump.
I think obviously.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
all that,
but the two big groups which are kind of
like well-educated,
sort of what I call generation from the
Internet trolley,
some outright he cultural libertarian
sort of trump supporters who by and
large are the best people in the world.
It's so funny and interesting and smart
and brilliant and I love them.
And the other group which had also the,
you know,
the,
some of the best people in the world,
um,
you know,
the,
the white working class who are,
you know,
who will rightly worried about the
direction of the company that the
country is taking
the company.
See soon it'll be a company that was
looking for me.
It took an hour,
but you see fascism comes with a smile
and bleach blonde hair.
I'm going to start calling it the firm.
We've got to fix the phone.
Basically you're saying that
these two groups,
the queen calls a royal family,
the firm,
I think in England,
she,
so these two groups coming together,
it will just have it.
Look,
I feel happy,
joyful,
wonderful people and I love them and
they're both of these groups in my
natural constituency,
both of these groups in my readers and
my viewers,
both of these groups,
I think hold with them united under,
under Daddy,
the promise of a better America.
I say that with no hint of,
of exaggeration.
I think these,
you know,
these groups,
think about the Gamer Gate,
you know,
saying when,
when,
um,
video game players the least likely kind
of group in the,
in the world to rise up and beat the
feminists.
And they did beat the feminist and they
were like,
really?
These,
you know,
everyone was thinking these parents'
basement guys and video games really?
And they won.
They did what?
Nobody,
none of the rest of us had done.
Well,
they woke this thing that I did not know
that this was happening as a direct sort
of,
um,
tributary to enter intergeneration
trump,
um,
you know,
and,
and they work people up to the fact that
if you turn around as a progressive left
and you say,
I'm not sexist,
go fuck yourself.
Nothing bad happens.
And in fact,
other people around you start to notice
and they start to do it too.
And these two groups together,
white working class,
um,
you know,
ordinary people who've seen wages
depressed and worried about where the
country is going and that very highly
in,
in a,
in a sort of highly education college
student and into their,
up to about 35 kind of cross like gen x,
millennial,
borderline people our age who are sick
of having been told what to do for 10
years by the aggressive regressive left.
This union of people,
the what I call generation trump is,
um,
is the most exciting cultural force that
has been in this country for decades.
Um,
and it's,
it's a group of people that I'm very
proud to be part of them to,
to have a role in because I think
they're great.
And I think,
um,
I think many of these people,
whether it's the gamers in that top end
or the,
you know,
people who just,
people just drive,
drive trucks for a living,
whatever.
These are some of the people who have
been lied to and lied about the most in
American Society for decades and they're
sick of it and they're right to be sick
of it.
Um,
and if they can drive into the White
House,
a candidate like trump who is going to
build a wall,
he's going to fix trade is going to do
these things.
And then if he doesn't do too much else,
that's not such a disaster.
I'm a candidate like trump who is going
to give the president establishment
journalists and politicians are like the
most colossal bloody nose and they
deserve it.
They have it coming,
you know,
they really deserve this.
Then I am fully behind it.
Yeah.
And ironically,
I think at that point you could make a
strong case that if Bernie does not get
the Democratic nomination,
that he should actually have a good
portion of his people should actually go
to trump because he's knows whether you
agree with Bernie or Hillary.
Obviously you're going to get the
nomination.
But the good thing about trump,
good thing that one of the things about
Saunas and trump supporters is a
relatively politically promiscuous that
they want is to hurt the bad guys and
the bad guys now the New York Times,
you know,
the political class,
the banks,
whatever,
you know,
all these people that um,
that,
you know,
controlling the rest of us and knowing
our own it not in our interests.
Um,
I think many of them will come over and
I think you'd be surprised just how many
come over because their concerns aren't
that different.
And when you look at,
um,
if you look at like the saunders rallies
and look at the trump rallies,
there's this similar sort of,
there's a sort of fun young,
exciting kind of atmosphere in both the
crowds.
They have a very similar feel to them.
The atmosphere at those events is in
many ways very similar and I think
people are more interested in the sort
of cultural ties across political lines
these days than they are with Republican
and Democrat labels.
Right,
right.
So those cultural ties,
that's really what brought us together.
So I guess to wrap all this thing up,
is that the left,
that portion of the left that you would
argue is probably 90 percent of the
left,
if not 100 percent plus me and one other
guy.
Uh,
but that will leave.
Yeah.
So.
Alright.
So you got million libertarian before.
So between.
Yeah.
Well I,
I,
at this point I would basically say I'm
a classical liberal libertarian
somewhere in there.
Um,
which actually,
believe it or not,
people don't like to hear it,
but it's actually on the conservative
side.
If you looked at liberal is watching
this,
you did this to him.
I mean,
you know,
you,
you forced leftists,
perfectly nice,
you know,
domesticated liberal,
gay man into talking about free speech
on the Internet.
You know,
crazy what happened here.
But see if they did something good
between the regressive left and the
authoritarians that between the power
structure of the media,
the politicians,
all that,
they did wake this thing up and that's
why me and you can sit here and do this
and still have a drink after and agree
and disagree and whatever.
And you did a good sell job,
you didn't bring me all the way but you,
but you lay out an interesting case and
that's what I'm interested in hearing,
you know?
And so they did do something because
they all have the people that are in
this mix now that we talk about all the
time,
you know,
from Rogan and Christina Hoff summers
and you know,
Sam Harris and budget and all of these
people all over the map have woken up.
So that to me is the takeaway that I can
feel good about with this regardless of
who becomes president regardless of the
political end of this,
that we're here and we're doing this.
And that's what,
that's what the authoritarians on either
side fear the most.
Correct.
And it's.
And I think it's an extra bowl.
I think it is irresistible.
If you look at the 19 nineties,
the emergence of political correctness
in the 19 nineties,
which was beaten back very successfully
by coalition like us.
We're the ones doing it now.
And although in the nineties,
these people,
as Christine Alexis,
I got the assistant professorships and
you know,
stayed in tenure and the and the
universities and all the rest of it had
to go away from the media but never
really went away.
They just sort of consolidated their
power and returned as social justice
warriors.
This time there's so much more on the
line for them because if it,
if they break this time,
they all breaking.
They all losing with the full support of
politicians,
the media and academia.
And if,
if people rise up now and say,
this social justice thing is language
policing,
this political correctness,
safe spaces,
trigger warnings and microaggressions,
this stuff is horseshit.
And if enough people smash it
stranglehold on the public square,
it will never recover.
It will never go.
Never come back in a like this again
because it will lose at the height of
its powers.
It will lose in its strongest possible
form.
It will lose,
as we say in,
you know,
in the Internet,
in its final form,
social justice cannot get any stronger
than it is now.
Um,
it is,
it is at,
it's at the peak of its powers and it's
losing.
It's losing because people want freedom.
They want to be able to do,
say,
think,
be,
play and read anything and they have the
faith in themselves and in other people
that they are able to make the best
judgments for themselves and what they
believe in.
They don't need to be told how to speak.
They don't need to be told which books
to read.
They don't need to be told which video
games a dangerous.
They don't need to be told any of these
things.
They don't need to be instructed and
lectured to by politicians.
They don't need to be badgered and
hectored by feminists and they don't
need to be lied to by journalists
and people are sick of it and they are
sick of the entire mendacious edifice
and this is what has happening so
wonderfully right now with people like
us and all the other conversations that
are happening in cultural libertarian
movement and in general what I call
generation trump and data and all this
kind of stuff.
The Fun,
mischievous trolley element on the
Internet.
What is behind all of this?
The heart of all of this is that
rejection,
that fundamental rejection of the idea
that somebody else knows better than I
do.
How I should live my life,
man.
You know how to give a closing argument.
I was really good,
right?
No cue cards over there at all in the
hands of professionals here for the
record.
I did not look at these once.
I had a lot of questions for you,
but I think we did a fine job here.
Uh,
so of course I want to thank Miley
Annapolis for joining me.
Thanks.
You guys can check out all his stuff at,
uh,
at Breitbart.com.
Follow him on twitter.
It's at Nero.
There are roughly how many,
how many copies of Youtube,
but I think I'm the most imitation
personal internet who,
yeah,
they created.
They created a Gremlin in water monster
with you.
How many?
Really
after midnight.
I don't know,
but if you have any audio like the
emperor who was awesome.
Um,
except for the Christian running,
everything else looks great.
Perfect.
Nobody's perfect.
Whenever is good.
You know,
he was,
I mean,
he was an egotist fine,
I'll take that.
You know,
he was self involved,
was fine.
He was spent too much money on himself,
you know,
he raised half of Rome,
a gigantic palace called the Dermis
area.
When he finally moved into the,
uh,
into the palace,
he,
I think is,
I think it was instantaneous.
I think he said to him,
finally,
I can start live as a human being.
I was hated by the elites.
There's senate,
hated him but loved by the people.
So,
um,
he was a good.
It was probably the best time.
So you want to throw this country to
accompany or do you want your palettes?
I got nobody who wouldn't want to live
in neuropathy.
There is no blue check,
but just take my word for it.
We'll do it again next week.